les républicains s'associent à la
douleur du monde agricole et adressent
leur condillance à la famille de
d'Alexandra Monsieur le Premier Ministre
leur fin fin sera notre fin faim la
colère des agriculteurs qui éclate dans
tout le pays frôle le point de nonretour
ne soyez pas étonnés c'est la
conséquence des promesses tombées aux
champs d'honneur qui ont fini de les
exaspérer votre majorité leur promet des
lois pour leur simplifier la vie pendant
qu' Parlement européen vous votez en
randonon la décroissance derrière
monsieur canampfin quelle imposture on
reporte sans cesse les réponses
attendues vous participez au déclin
deagriculture française ce n donc pas
simplement un projet de loi que vous
retardez mais l'avenir même de notre
agriculture et de notre souveraineté
alimentaire juillet automne décembre
janvier et finalement la LOA est
désormais annoncée après le salon
d'agriculture il y a encore quelques
jours vous étiez donc prêt à présenter
en conseil des ministres un texte bref
moins 10 an pour tenter d'acheter la
paix sociale agricole vous nous menez en
bateau les surtranspositions de normes
les contraintes sont toujours plus
pressentes les contrôles toujours plus
inquisiteurs pendant qu'à cô côté nous
accueillons des produits étrangers
suivant des règles que nous ne tlerons
pas chez nous ne soyez pas plus
royaliste que le roi sur les normes
agricoles vous interdisez certains
produits phytosanitaires mais vous ne
donnez que des miettes à la recherche
d'Alternativ vous n'assumez pas les
choix courageux des nouvelles techniques
de sélection variétal pour répondre aux
enjeux environnementaux les agriculteurs
vous réclament des prix vous bricolez
une pseudooi sur les négociations
commerciales sans effet cette Assemblée
nationale vote à l'unanimité la réforme
du système des retraites agricoles vous
mettez 12 mois à nous sortir un scénario
d'entrée en vigueur réveillez-vous les
agriculteurs n'ont pas à choisir entre
les adistes bourgeois qui les igouillent
et le citadin bardé la opportuniste qui
découvre les fermes avec les
républicains nous faisons un seul choix
leur faire confiance leur permettre de
vivre d'être bien rémunéré le diagnostic
est posé voici le remè gelle de la taxe
génr abrogation des surtranspositions
abusives maîtrise des charges sociales
investissement et autorisation pour le
stockage de l'eau révision des règles de
négociation alors Monsieur le Premier
Ministre quel
beauoup merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Marc F ministre
de l'Agriculture merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député d vous connaz
bien c connaissez bien ces sujets je
vais essayer de vous répondre sur un
certain nombre de points premier point
sur les sujets des négociations
commerciales je ne connais pas un
agriculteur ou une organisation
professionnel qui voudrait qu'on
revienne sur la loi Galim il nous
demande d'aller plus loin il nous
demande de vérifier d'aller au contrôle
donc ne dites pas que cette loi é
inutile cette loi elle a été un premier
pas sur la
rémunération cette loi elle est et on a
besoin que dans il a parlé des
négociation commerciale je crois me
semble que ça fait partie d'égal mais
donc on a besoin d'aller plus loin de
faire en sorte que la contractualisation
soit respectée de faire en sorte
d'inciter un certain nombre de filières
à rentrer dans égalim c'est ça qu'on a
besoin de faire on a besoin d'y
travailler ensemble deuxième est
l'élément sur la loi d'orientation nous
avions un texte effectivement centré sur
la question du renouvellement des
générations avec des moyens importants
qui ont été d'ailleurs votés
budgétairement dirai un mot juste après
il nous semble que dans le moment qu'on
traverse on a besoin d'accélérer sur un
certain nombre de procédures qui était
d'ailleurs et vous le savez inclus dans
le pacte et donc on a besoin s'il y a
besoin d'éléments législatifs de le
faire et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
prendre ce temps-là pour répondre
concrètement vous avez raison au demande
qui sont celles des agriculteurs et puis
nous avons un sujet européen monsieur le
député div c'est moi qui ai pris
l'initiative au nom de la France d'une
demande de de suppression de la
dérogation de la l'affaire desjchers des
4 % de jcher pour faire en sorte que
dans ce monde où nous importons en
Europe 40 millions de tonnes de céréales
on arrête de mettre en jacher en un
culture un certain nombre de terres
c'est la France qui a été rejointe par
22 pays maintenant on attend de la
commission qu'elle réponde et c'est le
combat que nous continuons à mener c'est
la France et c'est les délégations
françaises y compris de renaissance qui
a mené des négociations pour faire en
sorte que le texte sur la restauration
de la nature n'aboutisse pas à la mise
sous cloche de la nature alors oui il y
a des enjeux oui il y a des la batailles
à mener oui il y à faire en sorte que
dans le Green Deal on Vienne bien
conjuguer les transition parce que vous
le savez comme moi monsieur le député di
il y a besoin de transition il y a des
secteurs entiers de l'agriculture en
zone intermédiaire en particulier qui
sont en grande difficulté du fait du
dérèglement climatique mais on a besoin
de le conjuguer avec la souveraineté et
c'est ça et c'est ce combat là qu'il
faut continuer à mener y compris au
niveau
européen je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre